(electronic whooshing and beeping)
(gentle, relaxing music)
- I'm John Campbell,
I'm a philosophy professor
in the department here.
I'd like to welcome you to this
wet and rainy Howison lecture,
thank you for struggling through
the elements to get here.
George Holmes Howison was born in 1834.
When he was 50,
he came from the University
of Washington at St. Louis
to take the first endowed chair
in philosophy at Berkeley,
and he built the philosophy department.
He was evidently a charismatic
and much loved individual.
On his death, his friends and colleagues
put together a fund that
is funding today's lecture,
even still, to continue his work
by bringing the most
influential thinkers of the day
out here to the rural
wilderness of California.
And we're particularly
grateful to Philip Kitcher
for having made that long trek here today
to the rural sublime.
Philip Kitcher is a John Dewey
professor of philosophy
at Columbia University.
He did his PhD at Princeton,
having done his undergraduate work
at Christ's College in Cambridge.
He began as a philosopher
of mathematics and science,
but then focused on philosophy of biology,
and then on the role
of biological research
in society and politics,
and then on the role, generally,
of science in a democracy.
He said, following Dewey,
"I believe in the need for a
reconstruction of philosophy,
"so that it will not be
"a sentimental indulgence for the few."
I think it's fair to say
that his more recent,
I hope it's fair to say,
that his more recent work
has been deeply influenced
by John Dewey's pragmatism,
including pragmatism about ethics.
And coupled with the pragmatism,
a long standing adherence to
a quite radical naturalism.
He's written a flood
of well-received books,
the two most recent have been
Life After Faith: The
Case for Secular Humanism,
and The Seasons Alter:
How to Save Our Planet in Six Acts.
So not a sentimental
indulgence for the few.
He's also written on literature and music,
in particular, on Joyce and Wagner,
and on Thomas Mann and Muller.
So will you please join me
in welcoming Philip Kitcher.
His title today is
progress in the sciences
and in the arts.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, John.
Thank you very much, John,
for that extremely kind
and accurate introduction.
It's a great honor to give
a lecture in this series,
which has over the past
nearly 100 years, I think,
drawn to Berkeley,
to the rural wilderness
of Northern California,
an incredibly distinguished
series of philosophers,
and I feel slightly
humbled to be part of that.
But it's a great pleasure to be here,
and thank you very much for inviting me.
So what I want to talk about today,
and to the philosophy
department tomorrow as well,
is part of a project to save
what I think of as an endangered concept.
And that's the concept of progress.
Now, many people in the current
world celebrate progress.
Steven Pinker has recently written a book
about the importance of progress
of various kinds since the enlightenment.
But many people are also skeptical.
John Gray, for example,
has written a recent book
in which he questions the
possibility of progress.
He urges us to give up on the idea,
the myth as he thinks of
it, of human progress.
Now, there are many skeptics
about progress around,
some people who think that
it doesn't make sense,
that it serves merely as a concept
that we use to congratulate
ourselves unwarrantedly.
I'm a friend of the concept of progress,
but I have to also to admit
that I think that the skeptics
and the warriors are onto something.
I think that the breezy confidence
that Steven Pinker sometimes
displays is unwarranted,
and that this concept
deserves a deeper probing.
And I want to do part
of that probing today,
but in a very restricted set of context,
I want to talk about
progress in two domains,
in the sciences and in the arts.
And let me begin
by thinking about progress concepts.
Because I think many of the worries
that people have about progress
come from not thinking
carefully and precisely enough
about what a progress concept is.
And I'm going to do
something, graduate students,
this is a throwback to
the dim and distant past,
when people talked about the
logic of various concepts,
and I want to talk about the
logic of progress concepts.
So when you talk about progress,
you focus on something,
I'm going to call that thing, a system.
And you compare two of its states.
And you say, a change has occurred between
the former state and the later state,
and that change is a progressive one.
And you can do this for
any number of systems,
you could talk about the Catholic Church,
dividing time up according to papacies,
and ask whether the Catholic Church
is making progress under Pope Francis.
Or you could talk about the
theory of the chemical bond
and look at it at various stages
from the 19th century to the present,
and ask whether that
theory has made progress.
Or you could take a child,
or a young musician,
and ask, is this musician making progress?
And sometimes, it's useful to introduce
mathematical concepts in doing that,
that's especially so in
a fourth kind of case.
Imagine you have a friend
who's in the hospital,
there's some substance inside
your friend's body or in the bloodstream
or something like that,
that is different from what it should be,
perhaps it's too high.
And the doctors chart
your friend's progress
by looking at the ways in which
the concentration changes over time.
And if you had measurements
for each time point,
you could, as it were,
talk about continuous,
the continuous changes,
and the intervals in
which progress was made,
which it was not made.
So that's the first part of
the logic of progress concepts.
The second is that your progress concept
can be more or less ambitious.
You can set out to compare
any two temporal states
of the system that you're interested in.
You give me a pair of
years in the history,
let's say of New York City,
and I'll tell you which
one was progressive
with respect to the other one, okay?
Or you can be much more cautious and say,
well, I'm actually not really interested
in making all kinds of comparisons,
I just want to make some
kinds of comparisons.
And I'm particularly interested in
temporarily adjacent pairs of states.
That's because I often want
to use my progress concept
in deciding how to go on,
asking myself, would I make progress
by going in this direction
rather than that?
And you might then aim for something
that is locally complete.
That is you can make comparisons between
all pairs of temporarily adjacent states.
But even if you couldn't have that,
having some ideas about
which were progressive
with respect to which others
would still sometimes be very helpful.
The third part of my
logic of progress concepts
is the most important.
We tend to think of progress in terms
of narrowing the distance to a fixed goal
that's set out in advance.
So if you go on a family trip,
and you're going to a particular place,
then you measure your progress
by the diminishing distance
of yourselves from that place.
But much progress isn't like that.
There's another concept,
think of it in terms of progress from,
which I'll call pragmatic progress.
Pragmatic progress
occurs when you solve
some of the problems,
or expand some of the limits
of your current practice.
Okay, think about a technology,
I heartily dislike the
technology of the smartphone.
I don't actually own one.
I refuse to get drawn into this culture.
But the smartphone is not
oriented towards some platonic
ideal of the smartphone,
glimpsed by those who are lucky enough
to come out into the light
of Silicon Valley, right?
That's not the way it works.
People make progress with
respect to smartphone technology
by focusing on the glitches
and the difficulties
and the limits of current smartphones,
and trying to remove those.
So we get progress from a not progress
to any long term fixed goal.
Okay, so I've begun in
this rather pedantic
and sort of analytic philosophical mode,
because I want to draw some morals.
And the first of these
is that when we think
about progress in a domain,
like the sciences, or like the arts,
the first question we should ask is,
how are we defining the
states of these systems?
The second question that we might ask
is whether we're committed to
finding a progress concept
that will be so ambitious
that it will allow us to
compare any pair of states.
And the third is whether
we need to talk about
some long term enduring
goal fixed in advance.
So I'll start with the sciences.
And think about some popular
decisions that people make
when they talk about
progress in this realm.
The first of these popular decisions
is that when people think
about progress in science,
they say the things like,
we know more than we used to.
And that leads them to focus
on a set of propositions that are,
as is sometimes said,
on the books at a
particular moment in time.
We might think of those as
the corpus of propositions
accepted by the relevant
community at that time.
And then they make a further move
that progress is teleological,
they think of the sciences
as advancing towards
some sort of complete truth.
Perhaps it's the complete
truth about nature,
or perhaps it's the
complete truth in a domain,
as cell biologists might want to know
the complete truth about cells.
I want to suggest that both
of these things are problematic.
First, as has been familiar
for at least half a century,
there's far more to scientific practice
than a simple set of propositions.
The science of a time contains
lots of other things too,
it contains instruments,
techniques, rules of evidence,
and we can make progress
in all of these respects.
But more fundamentally,
the idea of scientific
progress as teleological
deserves serious scrutiny.
Think about the idea of the
complete truth about nature,
or the complete truth about any
significant aspect of nature.
As a goal for human inquiry,
that seems absurd.
If Paolo Mancosu were here,
I would ask him whether,
the truth, the whole truth about nature
might even be too big.
It's not even coherent to think about
the whole truth about nature.
But even if it is,
it's not something that we
could ever hope to attain.
So I think there are serious worries about
these standard ways of thinking
about scientific progress.
And I'll illustrate that by
thinking about this room.
How many truths are there about this room
for the period of this lecture?
Well, I was originally
trained in mathematics,
and when I think about this,
it's pretty easy to generate an answer.
There's some infinite number
at least as great as the
power of the continuum.
Why is that?
Because there are continuum
many spatial points in this room,
there are continuum many temporal points
in the interval that
this lecture will last.
And at each of those space time points,
there's going to be
values of particular physical magnitudes,
and then there are all
the two place relations,
the three place relations,
the four place relations, and so on.
You can see you get quite
a lot quite quickly.
Could any human language
express all of those truths?
If so, which language ought to be chosen?
How many potential languages are there
for recording these truths?
And how many of these
truths are worth knowing?
I hope the answer to the final
question is more than one.
If not, I'm in trouble.
Now, the obvious reply
to what I've just said,
is that that's a distortion
of the teleological approach
to scientific progress.
We don't want them, this
awful, vast mass of truth,
what we want is a special kind of truth.
We want nature's rulebook,
we want the axioms of
the fundamental theories
from which we could then derive
all of the other truths about nature.
Well, in principle, we
could derive all of them,
in practice, we could derive any of them
that are of interest to us.
So that's what we want.
And once we have that,
we can address any
question that concerns us.
This image of science remains
extremely popular among journalists,
among academics generally,
and among philosophers outside
of philosophy of science.
They think in terms of
a Newtonian picture,
the kind of thing that Newton
celebrated in the Principia,
where he says, I wish we
could derive all the phenomena
by ways similar to the
principles I've shown in
the theory of gravitation.
And scientists in various domains
have struggled to live up to that.
But it really doesn't work.
And it fails for two reasons.
First of all, there's vertical failure.
If you think of the sciences
as ordered in some kind
of vertical hierarchy,
physics could either be at
the top as the highest science
or at the bottom as the
most fundamental science,
then there's chemistry,
then there's biology,
then there's neuroscience
and there's psychology,
then there are things like
economics and sociology,
and so on and so forth.
The trouble is that you can't get
from the most fundamental
level all the way up,
because there are junctures
at which the derivations go astray.
You can't derive all the
allegedly special sciences
from the allegedly fundamental ones.
You can't, for example, get
genetics out of biochemistry.
But that's less important
than another point.
And that is what I'll
call horizontal failure,
to distinguish it from
the vertical failure.
And that is that universal
principles are rare.
They're welcome when we can find them,
but most of the time in most fields,
scientists have to settle for
a loose collection of models.
Models that will cover the cases
that are of most interest to them.
And sometimes no single model will do.
I suspect that in climate forecasting,
we are forever committed
to using a family of models
that will partially
agree with one another,
and will partially
diverge from one another.
The moral of my story
is that science then is
inevitably selective.
Scientists proceed by looking at
certain kinds of questions about nature.
And that agenda of questions
evolves over historical time.
And we might ask how it's determined.
Most of the time when we
think about a science,
we take it for granted that the scientists
are asking the right kinds of questions.
They are asking questions
about the genuinely significant things,
the things that we ought
to be asking about.
And almost all the time, I want to say,
that assumption is completely justified.
But it isn't always justified.
And looking at cases in
which it isn't justified,
points us in the direction of seeing
how there's something more fundamental
about scientific progress
than simply taking for granted
what scientists actually hail
as the questions that are significant
and important to answer.
So, let's go back to
the early 20th century,
and ask a question about genetics.
In 1900,
three scientists
independently rediscovered
Mendel's laws, or Mendel's rules,
as they were called at the time.
In 1925,
lots of things had already happened
in the development of genetics.
People had begun to understand
the relation between
genes and chromosomes,
they had used that to start gene mapping,
they were able to identify
all sorts of details of gene expression,
in particular organisms, in particular,
the fruit fly, Drosophila melanogaster.
All of that was terrific.
And inclines us to say, yes,
genetics was making fantastic progress.
But it was also doing something different.
The building you see there,
the Eugenics Record Office
is now Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory on Long Island.
And in the teens and the 20s,
it was set up to address
and come to terms with
socially important questions
about things like feeble mindedness
and the decline of the race.
Much of this, as was pointed out
wonderfully and lucidly by
the late Stephen Jay Gould,
was profoundly socially destructive,
and morally, extraordinarily dubious.
And there was a whimsical side to it too.
One of the genes that was sought
by the people earnestly involved
in this kind of research
was a gene for thalassophilia.
Those of you with a little Greek
will know what thalassophilia is,
it's a condition typically expressed
in males between the ages of 14 and 18,
that leads them to run away to sea.
Now, that sort of thing we
could take in our stride,
right, you're locating
genes on chromosomes,
you're mapping genes, you're
doing lots of good stuff.
Yeah, if scientists do a little bit
of peculiar whimsy on the
side, that's no big deal.
But the genes for feeble mindedness,
all of that attempt to understand
the genetic determinants of
socially consequential behavior
was profoundly worrying.
And so it seems to me that
the verdict on genetics
in the early 20th century has to be mixed.
And it has to be mixed
because the frame with
which we naturally start,
the frame of saying, well,
the scientists were asking
the important questions,
that assumption is suspect in this case.
We have to move to a wider frame,
and we have to ask about the way in which
the science is actually
embedded in society.
So I want to say that the
sciences make progress
when they contribute to
the wider human good.
They supply information
relevant to people's projects,
and that information is made accessible
to those who need it.
When scientists are doing that,
it is right to call
their answering of those
questions as progressive.
But sometimes, they pose
different kinds of questions,
and if those kinds of questions
have socially damaging consequences,
then we should not be so swift to declare
that the science in
question is making progress.
Some years ago, I tried to embed this
in an ideal of well-ordered science,
where I thought of the
common good as determined
through a process of deliberation
among representatives of various
points of view in the population,
who would try to identify
the questions in a field
that should be given priority
after they had informed one
another of one another's needs,
and after they were dedicated
to try to meet those needs.
And then well-ordered
science would also include
the thought that the
answers to those questions
flowed out into the general population.
And that gives me
a pragmatic sense of scientific progress,
science solves certain kinds of problems,
and the kinds of problems that it
should be solving to make progress
are the problems that
people need to have answers to.
And that means that what we have
is a broader sense of scientific progress
than the one that we started with,
one that involves certain
kinds of social elements.
All right.
Now I'm gonna turn to
the case of the arts.
Here, we make
a very simple way of thinking about this,
that dominates our
conversations about the arts.
We think about the state
of any mode of art,
music, or literature, or painting,
in any time period is
consisting in the works
that are produced during that time period.
And sometimes we think of one
period as superior to another.
Think about English drama
between 1580 and 1620,
and compare that with English
drama between 1620 and 1660.
Well, the first period wins, doesn't it?
I mean, the first period,
you have Christopher Marlowe.
You have John Webster,
John Ford, Ben Johnson,
George Peele, John
Fletcher, Francis Beaumont,
to name just a few of the people
who were around at that time.
And in the second period,
you're probably at a loss to name anybody
whose plays still survive,
anybody who was active.
Course I cheated, I chose my
periods extremely carefully.
And between 1620 and 1660,
well, the theaters were actually shut down
for part of that time under Cromwell,
and that didn't really encourage
a lot of terrific playwriting.
So I mean, it's a bit of a cheat,
on the other hand, you can see the way
in which this is supposed to work.
So the popular conclusions are,
the arts don't make progress at all,
but the sciences, by contrast,
are the parade case of progress.
Well, we've examined the scientific case,
and I hope I've shown you
what I think lies behind it.
But it's deeply unfair.
And the unfairness can be demonstrated
when we look at the
ways in which we define
those original states for the two cases.
In the case of science,
we said that the state
consists of a set of resources,
propositions and instruments
accepted at that time,
and available for use by the
people who live at that time.
And progress consists in the fact that
those resources accumulate
and become better adapted
to the needs of the people.
In the case of the arts,
we defined the state very differently.
We just looked at the works
produced during a time period.
And so in the case of music,
we might say music doesn't make progress.
Did the music of 2015
make progress over the music of 1905?
Get serious,
nothing composed in 2015
rivals Debussy's La mer,
or Schoenberg's first String Quartet.
And then there are some pieces by Webern,
and I can throw in a bit of Desur too.
Or if you incline to popular music,
nothing written in the last decade
rivals the music of The
Beatles, The Stones,
The Grateful Dead, all those great people
of the 60s and early 70s,
you know, get serious about it, okay?
So, good, let's apply that same standard
to physics, for example.
No physical discovery of 2015,
see, I chose my dates carefully, again,
rivals what Einstein did in 1905.
Four papers, the one that I've got there
is the famous paper on special relativity,
but we shouldn't forget the
paper on E equals MC squared,
paper on Brownian motion,
the black body radiation paper, you know.
I think any one of those papers dominates
pretty much what the physics
community produced in 2015.
So, you know,
what's sauce for the goose
is sauce for the gander,
if we do it one way in one case,
shouldn't we do it the
same way in the other case?
But the real point of this, of course,
is to get you started
on thinking differently
about progress in the arts,
not to suggest that progress
doesn't occur in the sciences.
The physics available today
includes what Einstein
contributed in 1905.
Indeed, practicing physicists
don't have to go back and read
those early Einstein papers.
They're available in smoother
and technically more accessible forms
in the textbooks from
which the physicists learn.
And the music available today
includes what Debussy and
Schoenberg composed in 1905,
and what The Beatles and The Stones
and the rest of them
did in the 60s and 70s.
And so in both cases,
we might say there's progress,
science and the arts,
and expanding collection of resources
that help with human lives
and human flourishing.
So what I want to say
about both of these cases,
is that the concepts
of progress that apply
are local, not global,
I don't think we can make all comparisons,
and pragmatic, not teleological.
And in both cases,
what we get is an
accumulation of resources
that help human beings to live better.
And this also brings to our attention
something that I won't stress today,
but I think it's an important point,
that in both instances,
it's an important part of overall progress
that there should be
institutions and parts of society
that make those resources
widely accessible.
So the ways in which the sciences
and the arts flow out into the public,
are also very important.
And without them,
we might not be as confident as we are
in talking about the progress of science
or the progress of the arts.
But we shouldn't stop.
I've only so far scratched the surface
of both of these domains.
I want to ask what exactly
the contributions that these domains make,
because maybe there are
residual differences
when we look more closely at
the kinds of contributions
made by the arts and by the sciences.
So let's talk about the
scientific contributions.
I usually say when I
talk about this topic,
you know, if I went out on the street,
and I asked people on the street,
what is it that the sciences contribute
that makes us think of them as
important parts of human progress?
I usually say, well,
what you typically get
is stuff about medicine,
agricultural innovations,
bits of technology.
I suspect that isn't true in Berkeley.
I suspect if I went out
on the street in Berkeley,
I might get a different answer,
I might get what I'm going
to call the official view,
that what we actually get from science
is an increased understanding
of the universe and its operations.
Ah, it's not all the medicines,
it's not all the new food stuffs,
it's not all of that.
It's not the bits of technology,
it's the human understanding that we get,
that's what's really crucial.
And this was brought home to me
when I came back from a
run a couple of years ago.
And I ran into a friend of mine,
who's a theoretical physicist who said,
"You've gotta listen to the radio,
"gotta listen to the
radio, 10:15 this morning,
"it's the greatest scientific
announcement of our lifetime."
He was born in the same year I was,
so I knew that what he said was false,
since the greatest scientific
achievement of our lifetime
was made when we were six,
when Watson and Crick discovered
the molecular structure of DNA.
But I didn't want to
sort of spoil his fun.
And what he was alluding to
was the detection of gravitational waves.
All right.
That for him, and for his community,
is what's really important
about scientific progress,
the increase in understanding.
Now, when we turn to the arts,
it seems that these
appear much more nebulous.
And that might be because
when people think about the
contributions of the arts,
they think, they compare them
to the practical benefits of science.
So if the everyday view
is the dominant view,
I think one can understand why people say,
ah, the arts, they don't
contribute as much,
they aren't as important
in us accumulating these resources,
the things that are really important
are the practical stuff.
So I wonder whether the popular comparison
actually presupposes what
I call the everyday view,
rather than the official view
adopted by my friend, the
theoretical physicist.
I want to answer the question,
what do the arts contribute,
in a Deweyan pragmatist style.
I want to think about the arts
as enriching human experience.
And I want to think of this
as having a number of different dimensions
of which I'll list three today.
First is the intensity of
aesthetic experience itself.
Just the fact of engaging
with a work of literature,
or a work of visual art or a film,
or a performance of dance,
or with a building, or
with a piece of music,
brings us to moments where I think we feel
vitally alive and an intensity that is
absent quite a lot of
the rest of the time.
So that I think is an
important part of it.
But this isn't,
these are not simply
isolated events or episodes,
these are things which
often it seems to me
recur in our further experience.
So that later experiences that we have had
are transformed by the aesthetic
experiences of the past.
What, our relation to a particular poem,
our relation to a piece
of music or to a painting
informs the way that we
have further experiences.
And they interact with one another
in ways I will want to
try to sketch later on.
And that can lead not simply to
an enrichment of our experience over time,
but also, I think, to cognitive gains.
So I'm taking a stand here,
a Deweyan stand on issues in aesthetics
that often divide theorists.
I'm saying, I'm putting in
my case for pluralism.
That we should not think about
all individual works of art as valuable,
in the same way and for the same reason,
because they may do differently
on these different dimensions
of aesthetic contribution.
So I think in the case of works of art,
they give us new cognitions,
but they don't do it by
informing us directly,
by asserting or arguing with us.
The novels and works of literature
that argue with us and that are didactic,
I think in particular of Sartre here,
rather than Camus,
seem to me less effective
than the works that show us things.
But the cognitive contributions
come from modifying the
ways in which we approach
other parts of our experience,
they show us new possibilities.
And I want to say they sometimes
provide us with new vocabularies,
they refigure the starting points
and methods of our discursive reasoning.
When we think about
cognitive contributions,
I think we have a tendency to think
as if they consisted in
providing us premises
from which we might then draw
new and different conclusions.
But I don't think that great works of art
and literature work that way.
I think they show us things
that lead us to conceptual revision.
And that is not necessarily
something that occurs in the moment.
It's something that occurs
through the rebuilding
of something in our psychology
that I'm going to call
a synthetic complex.
So think about the ways in which you react
when you read a work of fiction or a poem,
or when you listen to a piece of music,
or when you look at a picture
that really moves you.
You pass through a sequence
of psychological states,
and those are partly shaped
by your antecedent judgments
and conceptions and emotions,
and partly the product of your
apprehension of the words,
the colors and the sounds.
Out of that process
comes something different.
And it's something that unfolds
in your reflection on it,
and in the interaction between
what has happened to you
and your further experience,
that rebuilds the ways in which
your emotional and cognitive dispositions,
and your dispositions
to use various concepts,
fit together.
And so you get a restructuring
of a part of your psychological life.
This happened, I think,
I mean, I will give two very
simple and obvious cases.
This happened for some Victorian
readers of Dickens' novels,
when they read not only
Dickens' descriptions of
the plight of the poor,
but also Dickens' vocalizations
of the reactions of the bourgeoisie,
to the plight of the poor.
People came to see
themselves in those voices,
and they didn't like what they saw there.
And it came famously in
Harriet Beecher Stowe's
novel Uncle Tom's Cabin,
in some ways as a work of literature,
it's not a wonderful piece of writing,
but boy is it powerful
in changing the ways in which people think
about their social relations with others.
Even if Lincoln didn't say
to Harriet Beecher Stowe when he met her,
"So you're the little lady
who started this great war,"
it's something it seems to
me, he ought to have said.
So I think the same thing goes on
in our interactions with
bits of science, sometimes.
I think scientific understanding
can do the same sort of thing.
I think it did that for Richard Dawkins,
who's written eloquently about this,
and who says, very often,
you know, "How unfortunate
are those people
"who are deprived of seeing the world
"through a Darwinian lens,
"look at what they are missing."
And I resonate with that in Dawkins,
I can see why he says it,
and I think I can
understand the phenomenon
to which he is pointing.
But now, I want to ask a question.
We won't have a vote on this.
But when I've asked questions of people
I've talked to about this
material in the past,
I get a fairly strong reaction.
And that is that most people
in whom I ask about this,
after they've heard me talk about,
you know, art and science
and along these or similar lines,
will say, yeah, actually, for me,
it's the works of literature I've read,
it's the music I've heard,
it's the films I've seen.
That's what's done most for me
in having an impact for change in my life.
But many people who are deeply immersed
in the practice of the sciences will say,
no, it's the sciences.
I don't want to make judgments about this,
I think there are possibly temperaments
that lead people into different
areas of work and research,
and some people may, because
of their temperaments,
be more inclined to pursue courses of life
that lead the arts to be
more important for them
than the sciences.
Another question we might ask
is whether within the sciences themselves,
these artistic reshapings
play a critical role
at moments of great scientific change.
That's a thesis that Thomas Kuhn,
who once taught here at Berkeley,
floated in a book that he wrote
before the structure of
scientific revolutions,
in his book on the Copernican revolution.
So I'm going to,
just a moment of subversion,
a subversive thesis.
If scientific progress is understood
in terms of the pure benefits
of greater understanding,
maybe the case for progress in the arts
is stronger than that, for
progress in the sciences,
because of the phenomenon
to which I've just alluded.
The fact that it seems
that for most people,
it's works of art that have this
transformative impact on their lives.
But there's a residual difference,
and this is going to lead me back
towards the worries with which I began.
Scientific progress, you might say,
is cumulative in ways that
progress in the arts isn't.
And that's because of a phenomena
that I pointed to earlier,
that the scientists don't have to go back
and read Einstein's 1905 relativity paper.
The later stages of a science absorb
and they build on the
efforts of earlier stages,
whereas the arts, always are looking for
new ways forward, new forms of creativity.
In the words of Harold Bloom,
"Poets engage in strong
misreadings of their predecessors."
They don't, sort of,
just thrust them into the past,
they wrestle with them and
come to something entirely new.
Now in changing environments,
new directions in art,
and sometimes new genres
of art are needed.
The works of literature
that might have satisfied
one particular generation living
in a particular kind of world don't speak,
or they don't speak vividly and forcefully
to people who live later.
And that's because the
environments in which we live,
physical, social and cultural can change.
So art we might think
of as constantly renewed
to adapt to the features of the age.
Not all past artworks
lose their significance
by any means, that's for sure.
In the history of the string quartet,
the great string quartets
of the 20th century,
Schoenberg's, Bartok's, Janacek's,
don't make Beethoven and
Haydn and Mozart irrelevant.
But by contrast,
the words and things that
all the scientists produce
are often hidden
by the accomplishments
of their successors.
So nobody would go back
and try to learn chemistry
from Lavoisier's revolutionary book.
Nobody interested in astronomy today
would pick up Galileo's telescope.
Interestingly though,
biologists still turn back to Darwin.
Darwin is one of the
great exceptions to this.
Darwin continues to be relevant
to the biology of today.
And in this process, there's a change.
And I think Eliot caught this
in his essay on tradition
and the individual talent.
Where he says, "No poet,
no artist of any art
"has his complete meaning alone.
"You cannot value him alone,
"you must set him for contrast
"and comparison among the dead.
"What happens when a new
work of art is created
"is something that happens simultaneously
"to all the works of
art which preceded it."
And that means that there are gains
and losses with respect to the arts.
And that happened with respect to poetry
because of the kind of poetry
that Eliot and his friends wrote.
After Eliot, Pound and Yates,
Dante, Donne and Tennyson
get read differently.
Dante is somehow elevated,
he's somehow much more relevant,
much more important than he had seemed,
say, to the Victorians.
Donne emerges from being a quirky
odd figure in the 17th century,
to being a lively and interesting
and profoundly relevant poet.
And poor Tennyson,
the beloved poet of the mid
19th century and beyond,
somehow sounds lesser than he did.
If you listen to Schoenberg's
third string quartet,
and then listen to Beethoven's
third Rasumovsky quartet,
as I once did at a concert in Berlin,
where they played them in that order,
the Beethoven sounds
completely different after the Schoenberg,
and you can understand why
the first performance of
the Rasumovsky quartets,
the musicians protested,
tore up the scores and trampled on them.
I mean, it suddenly sounds
incredibly revolutionary.
So these things, this point
that derives from Eliot,
I think, raises a possibility,
the possibility of loss.
That you can lose access
to a former work of art
that might have been valuable for you.
And I wonder whether the same can happen
with respect to the sciences.
But the important theme
that I want to draw
from this general phenomenon,
concerns something that I think is
deeply lying behind the skepticism
about progress with which I began.
And that's the idea of people somehow
being at odds with their
own times with the age.
You know, I have already confessed,
I don't own a smartphone,
so maybe I am one of these people.
I think it makes sense
to say of some people
that their lives would have gone better
if they'd lived in earlier times,
that their temperaments and talents
are more adapted to those times.
And that means that we might think
that the artistic or scientific resources
available at a later time,
do not allow the people living at the time
to live as well as they would have done
at some earlier time.
They are less well adapted
than they would have been.
And this means that my comparison
on which I have been building
throughout this lecture,
is only one possible way
of making these comparisons.
There are in fact, two concepts
that we might focus on in thinking about
socially embedded notions of progress
for the arts and the sciences.
The first says, fix the environment.
Fix the present.
Ask whether life in this environment
would go better with the
resources of the past
or with those of the present.
That's what I've used,
and I've said, well,
in the present, typically,
you have most of the resources
that you would have had in the
past and a few more besides,
and in both cases, probably the things
that are developed in the sciences
are adapted to the differences
that have emerged in the present.
So progress comes quite easily.
But ask a different question.
Consider life with the past resources
in the past environment,
compare it with life with
the present resources
in the present environment.
If you do that, you may
not get the same answer,
you might get different verdicts.
So there are two notions or
two standards for progress.
I want to say that a practice like science
or art or religion
would make weak progress
if the developments
between the earlier stage
and the later stage enable those
who live at the later stage to live better
than they would have done
if the earlier form of the
practice had continued unaltered.
That's the notion where
you fix the environment.
It makes strong progress
if the developments made between
the earlier stage and the later stage
enable those who live at the later stage
to live better than those who
lived at the earlier stage.
The people who are
skeptical about progress
are skeptical often about strong progress.
And I haven't really responded
to what they say here.
That's because I think
that they have a point.
So I'll conclude, I think
weak progress is very common
in the histories of both
the sciences and the arts.
I think strong progress often occurs
in the histories of the
sciences and the arts.
But in both cases,
there may be significant periods
during which strong progress is not made.
And worries about strong progress
underlie the common forms of
skepticism about progress,
and those need to be
addressed and dealt with.
Now, how does it come about
that strong progress fails
where weak progress happens?
The answer lies in a point
I alluded to earlier.
When we focus on individual domains
of human life and human practice,
it's completely possible
for all of them internally
to make progress.
And yet for them not to contribute overall
to human well being
because of interaction
effects between them.
And that suggests that
if you are interested and thinking about
not simply being a pessimist,
human progress is impossible,
but actually trying to
build on those cases
in which both strong and weak progress
have happened in human history.
And as Dewey wanted,
make them more systematic and sure-footed,
then you'd better attend
to this kind of phenomenon.
And for that, you need an account
of how various kinds of institutions
and areas of human life fit together.
So I want to conclude
with a confession of a
pragmatist meta philosophy,
this is drawn very largely from Dewey.
And it's this.
Wilfrid Sellars famously says
that the point of philosophy,
what philosophy aims to understand
is how things in the
largest sense of the term
hang together in the
largest sense of the term.
And that seems to me, right.
And it's important,
because in each age,
philosophy should be in the
business of trying to understand
how in that age, the
conceptions and the practices
that the age has inherited,
fit together and hang together.
And without that,
without that kind of systematic
attempt to understand
what the various parts and enterprises
in which people engage,
do in combination with one another,
we can't hope to do what Dewey hoped,
which was to make human
progress more systematic
and sure-footed than it is.
This is just the tiniest beginning
of an attempt to work out a version
of that kind of Deweyan pragmatism
by focusing on a phenomenon
that I think is not well understood,
and to which I hope to have
brought a little bit of clarity.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
I think there's a stark
distinction that I would
have expected you to draw
that you didn't draw,
and so I want to question
whether your pragmatism sort
of commits you to reject it,
and that's just the distinction between
epistemic progress and social progress,
so it seems like that could be
deployed to analyze the
eugenics case, right?
And it seems in general,
sort of enlightenment picture of science
would have it that in general,
epistemic progress would
further social progress.
And perhaps in general social progress
would further epistemic progress,
but they can come apart, right,
so you can have epistemic progress
that hampers social progress,
the eugenics case would be a case of that.
And, you know, you could
get all four varieties.
That seems like a natural picture, right,
and provides a natural
diagnosis of a lot of cases,
is that a distinction,
is part of your view
rejecting that distinction?
- Actually, yes.
And the argument was given,
but perhaps too quickly,
and perhaps the argument is confused.
So let me try again.
What I want to say is that
the concept of epistemic progress itself
is to be cashed out in terms of
answering significant questions,
and that raises the question
of what counts as significant.
And what I'm then doing is
tying the notion of significance,
not only to some picture,
some model of understanding,
that might be shared
only by a tiny minority,
but to the needs of a
much broader society.
So I'm saying that a concept that figures
in the notion of epistemic progress
is itself socially and morally laden.
So that's the way in
which I'm trying to block
the simple separation you give, right?
I mean,
if the scientific community
answers the wrong questions,
however good its answers
are to those questions,
it's not making progress.
This is sometimes put
in the form of fantasies
about scientists going off
and pursuing completely trivial things.
But to me, it seems to
me the more forceful
version of that is when scientists
start addressing questions
that are not only socially relevant,
but socially harmful,
and that's the point of the eugenics case.
I mean, interestingly enough,
the scientific community
that I am analyzing there,
the community of scientists
from 1900 and 1925,
wouldn't have
made the distinction you make, right?
And we should remember that.
- [Audience Member] Thanks so much,
that was really interesting.
I just wanted to go back to
something you said about science
towards the beginning of the talk,
when you mentioned genetics between,
what, 1900 and 1925.
And you pointed out that
there was sort of progress
among some measures,
but not along others, which
seems absolutely right.
And then you went on to outline
your sort of conception
of well-ordered science,
where what science should
be up to is contributing to
the kinds of goods that
would be decided on
by some ideal rational deliberation
between scientists and the public,
I'm not sure of the
details, but something of.
And it sounded--
- Perhaps I shouldn't have said that.
- [Audience Member] It sounded like you,
one way of hearing what you were saying,
I don't think this is what you meant,
but one way of hearing
what you were saying was,
this is the dimension along
which to measure progress,
namely, is the science doing better
with respect to contributing
to what would be decided
at the result of this
ideal deliberative process.
And one way, I guess
one way of hearing that
makes it sound kind of teleological,
you know, like suggesters like the truth,
that says, look, there's
this thing truth out there,
and we've gotta measure it,
progresses to whether
we're approaching it.
Especially when you build
in the idealization.
It starts to sound like
there's this thing out there,
and we should measure
science as to whether
we're approaching it.
Now, I don't think that's
probably what you did mean,
so the question is, could
you elaborate on it?
- So actually, I mean,
I think it may have been
a mistake to talk about
the ideal of well-ordered
science in that context.
What I wanted to do
was to give some kind of substance
to the idea of science
contributing to the common good.
And my way of doing that
is to envisage what would be,
this goes back to my
sort of pragmatist views
about ethics and ethical method.
That goes back to the
idea that that emerges
from a certain kind of
engagement with others,
where we take one another's needs
and wishes and aspiration seriously,
and seek, using the best
information we have,
an outcome that all of us can live with.
Now, that as an ideal
is not intended to be
a specification of a final
state we could reach.
That as an ideal functions
as a diagnostic tool
for trying to identify in the present,
the places that are problematic.
And so what I would want to do
is suggest that
we make progress of a certain kind,
which is in a gender setting, say,
by making those kinds of decisions better,
so that we come to do
better at figuring out
what kinds of subjects and questions
would be pursued in a situation
where people were more
attuned to one another
and more willing to
deliberate in this way.
And that we then use that
as a measure of how to assess
scientific progress more generally.
And I'm being quite
liberal in most of the talk
about the standard,
I'm taking it for granted.
I mean, even if the
molecular biologists of today
are not doing the best
they could possibly do
at figuring out what the question,
they're doing pretty well, right?
And I'm gonna cut them some slack on that.
I mean, I think that actual
scientific communities
most of the time,
are asking the right kinds of questions.
And that if we've moved in the direction
of having the kinds of scrutinies
and deliberations around
what kinds of topics
are best to pursue,
that the public would
rightly endorse them.
So what I'm suggesting is,
yeah, pretty much everything is fine,
but there are going to
be these anomalous cases,
and the anomalous cases show up
when we start thinking
about the common good
in the terms that I've attempted to.
So I mean, there's a
sense in which there's,
there's something a little
bit vertiginous about this,
because the standard that
is used as it were to assess
the contribution to the common good,
is a standard itself that we
can only apply imperfectly
and with respect to which we
also need to make progress.
More about this tomorrow.
- [Audience Member] So
I wanted to ask about
textbooks a little bit,
because this is one place
where the disanalogy
seems to come out.
So in physics,
a textbook might explain
an idea in a way that
everyone thinks is more perspicuous
than the original presentation by Einstein
or whoever, the original.
Usually, there's some rough edges,
there's some conceptual
missteps and things,
these get cleaned up.
And the textbook gives you the idea,
the same idea, but better.
But that's very different
from what happens in music.
So a music professor or
a music textbook doesn't
rewrite a Beethoven quartet better,
so that everything essential
that you were supposed to get
out of the Beethoven quartet,
you now get in a more perspicuous,
better, more effective form.
Instead, they just tell you
to listen to the Beethoven quartet.
- Exactly.
- [Audience Member] So why,
I guess I didn't quite see
what your take is on that,
in the end.
- It leads into something about which I'm,
with which I'm struggling,
and that is the...
So I'll say another Deweyan thing.
Dewey says, at one point,
that any general philosophical
account of something
is tested in the crucible of
its consequences for education.
And so you've thrust me into
the consequences for education.
Now, in the case
of the sciences,
if we are really interested in
improving understanding,
improving the, as it were,
the transformative effects
that the sciences can potentially give
in people's psychological lives,
what we want is just what you described.
Efficient, perspicuous ways of identifying
what's really essential.
In the case of artworks,
what we want is making those artworks
accessible to individuals.
And it seems to be a
consequence of my views,
it's a consequence I accept,
that education in the arts
has to be as more complicated,
and more difficult than
education in the sciences.
And that's because
in the evolution of our
social environments,
genres proliferate, styles proliferate,
and if you're thinking
about a young person,
for whom, you know, there's this
massive collection of resources,
how can that person be led to find
the things that are going to
have the transformative
effect on him or her.
That suggests that we
actually need to spend
an enormous amount of time
and think very, very seriously
about how we do education in the arts,
whereas education in the sciences
poses another challenge to us.
I mean, if you're really,
if you take the transformative
view that I have,
then the emphasis on
education in the sciences
should be precisely at getting
this kind of conceptual clarity
with respect to the
fundamental breakthroughs
and the big ideas in the sciences,
and also the understanding of
the methods of the sciences.
And it should be much less
on learning lists of amino acids
or memorizing diagrams about
complicated relations within the cell,
and all of that sort of thing.
And I think, at the moment,
both forms of education
in the affluent countries
suffer from the fact that we think,
in the scientific case,
that we should, as it were,
force everybody through this pathway,
which is necessary for those
who are going to want to do
creative work in the sciences to traverse.
And what that has done to
very many young people,
I think, is deaden the
scientific curiosity
with which they start.
And so I don't know how to do this,
or I don't know how to
formulate this recommendation,
but it seems to me important
that up to a certain age,
we should treat all people as if
they were potentially
wanting to become scientists.
But then there comes a moment
at which what we want to do is imbue this
sort of tremendous sense of,
we wanna retain and imbue
this tremendous sense of natural
curiosity about the world,
with the conceptual framework
that will enable the people then to,
you know, to continue to engage
with the scientific discoveries
that will occur in their lifetimes.
In the case of arts, it's different,
that people will come in,
they will differ in the
kinds of art forms they like,
kinds of genres they like,
they will differ in the
kinds of styles they like.
And individual attention
seems to be needed
both to take them to the initial things
that are valuable for them,
to give them a sense of what it is
to have that kind of
transformative engagement with art,
and then to try to broaden
from that to build.
And these tasks, I think,
are practically enormously difficult.
And it's a consequence of my view
that they have to be undertaken.
So I take your point
as a completely correct observation about,
but it's an observation about, in the end,
about the different needs
of education in these areas.
- [Audience Member] When
you were talking about
gains and losses,
I had an association, or I
started a train of thought
that was not really in
what you were saying.
But I started thinking about
the kinds of dynamic of gains and losses
that happen in any conversation.
Something said at the
beginning of the conversation,
appropriate to the beginning,
maybe later on in the conversation with,
it's been superseded
by other insights that
we've gathered or we've produced.
And then I started thinking,
well in the life of a
marriage, think of all the,
how every time you say
something to your partner,
it resonates with things you would have,
the way you would have said that
at an earlier stage in the relationship,
or the reasons why you
say it this way now,
and you're using a turn of
phrase that she used before,
and you're using it now and knowing
that she'll know that you used it.
There's this history,
this thick history that
informs the present,
and describes a kind of progress,
or a kind of ongoing
life of the party, life of the culture,
because you can scale this up.
And I was wondering if in a
way your idea about art was,
if that was kind of the
picture you were suggesting,
that the kind of transformations,
the kinds of episodes,
that the work of art takes part of,
the kinds of transformations
that affords you
are like that, they're
embedded in this conversation.
And this is related to the
educational point of view,
because in some sense,
the kind of conversation we do in the lab
is different than we do in the culture.
And one of the things,
imagine our students,
they're coming late to the party.
And there's a lot of talk
that's been going on,
many bottles of wine have been drunk.
And we want to sort of
get them to figure out
how to listen to what's going on now,
which is a function of
what's been going on.
And that happens very
differently in the context of art
than in the context of science.
- I think that's right.
I mean, one of the points I made about
the Deweyan conception
of the value of art,
is that
the work continues to resonate with you,
and its later impact on you is dependent,
not only on the changes that
were produced at the time,
but the way those changes have
led to further interactions
in your subsequent experience.
And that, of course, I mean,
in many cases, the process
of psychological change
that goes on in relation
to a particular work of art
for an individual can last a lifetime.
It can be like a very
long, enduring marriage.
So I mean, with respect to Joyce,
I come back to Joyce
again and again and again,
and it's always different.
It's always, there's
always new things there.
There's always something that
points me in new directions,
and that's because of the
ways in which I've grown.
But it's also because of the order
in which a particular series of
previous interactions occur.
So I think that's right.
I wonder whether that's entirely absent
from thinking in the sciences?
I'm not talking now about, you know,
students coming to understand things,
but I'm talking about in the
life of a creative scientist.
It seems to me that there's
a lot of room for contingency
built in, in both of these domains.
It's not inevitable that
once you start down a particular line,
it has to go in this direction,
it could have gone quite differently.
I mean, I think that's one of the things
that in retrospect is unnerving
about the general phenomenon of progress.
That is when we look back on
many episodes in the past,
that we count, and perhaps
with very good reason,
as being episodes of progress,
we realized how easily
they could have gone
in different directions.
So contingency is unnerving, I agree.
- I wonder if \I could follow up
on Dewey for a moment.
The first sentence of art as experience
is one of the great
sentences in aesthetics,
it's something like,
the thing that gets in the way of
framing inadequate theory of art,
is the existence of the
art objects themselves,
on whose basis we frame such a theory.
And his ideas that we think the art
is somehow intrinsic to
the object or the thing,
when in fact, the thesis of the book
is that art is experience.
Art literally is experience.
He then goes on, and offers
a theory of experience,
according to which all
experiences are aesthetic.
Because for him, aesthetic is,
it's a condition on being an experience,
that it has a certain kind of integration,
a balancing of parts.
So that--
- So I'm gonna read
Dewey a bit differently,
because it seems to me that
the dominant in the book
is a tone of regret,
that precisely because of the
divorce between everyday life
and the art world, the
world of art objects,
experience has become
flattened for people.
So Dewey wants desperately
to restore the creative part,
the idea not just of the
individual as a consumer
of artworks which are produced elsewhere,
but the, as it were,
the interaction with
other people's artworks
as being an interaction with
one's production of things oneself.
And that makes the answer
to this earlier question
about education even more complicated,
because it suggests that
a part of the development
of the young person who comes
to interact fruitfully with works of art
consists in bringing about the conditions
where that person can find his or her own
creative work of art.
So I mean, I think,
yeah, I know that Dewey is inclined
to sort of go off the end
and say all experience is aesthetic,
but that really is quite at odds with the,
I think this very important
theme in art as experience.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
Yeah, so I was wondering how your account
would treat two different sorts of
periods in the development of science.
So like, the first being one, in which,
as the discoveries are being made,
it seems that the common
good is being benefited.
Like say, if we take for granted that
the development of technology
in the 20th century
greatly benefited the
people who lived through it
but accelerated climate change.
So, you know, a period that then runs into
those sorts of future
worsenings of the common good,
and then kind of the flip side of that,
periods in which maybe
we're not asking questions
that seem like they would be fruitful,
we're not making
discoveries that are helping
the common good of our contemporaries,
but eventually, it becomes
clear in retrospect
that we were laying the
foundations for necessary,
or sorry, we're laying
necessary foundations
for discoveries that would help people.
And I guess a slight sub
question to that second part,
sorry, this is getting really long,
is because that often
does happen in science,
where we'd start out by asking questions
that lead us to results that
are completely unpredictable,
take us in different directions
and could end up
benefiting the common good.
I'm curious what bearing that might have
on your prescription for trying to model
asking the right questions, like ones that
would be democratically
chosen, more or less.
Thank you.
- Excellent questions.
There are two questions,
one is about what what happens when
we've got these unforeseen,
ghastly consequences?
And the answer there is, you know,
it's perfectly justifiable
for people at the early stages
to think they're making progress,
and maybe they are making
progress for a while.
But it's not part of my thesis
to suppose that if you go
on doing the same thing
that is genuinely progressive earlier,
there can't come a point at which it tips
and goes the other way.
So with respect to quite a
lot of environmental issues,
actually, one could say,
so people engage initially in something
that's genuinely progressive,
they keep doing it,
and it keeps being
progressive for a while,
but then there comes a moment
at which they think of
themselves as making progress,
but then they're wrong, okay.
So that's the way in which
I want to address that kind of case.
The other case is also I think,
very challenging and very interesting.
So it is surely the case
that there are going to be occasions
on which you get unpredictable
in advance benefits from pursuing
a particular line of investigation.
So let's now put this in the framework
of people deliberating about, as it were,
what projects to fund or
what projects to pursue.
So the flat footed way
of doing this is to say,
well, you go to the
things that are obviously
going to meet the needs of
the people here and now.
But I want my deliberators
to know some things
about the history of science too,
and one of the things I want them to know
is that in the course of
the history of science,
sometimes the indirect route
has been very important,
and that sometimes it's
been very good just to let
people who have apparently
irrelevant questions to ask,
follow their hunches.
So I used to always tell my students
in philosophy of biology that
there were two strategies
in the early decades of the 20th century
for coping with human disease.
One is, let's go do the
genetics of human disease
right now using Mendel's methods, okay?
And the other was, let's
think about fruit flies,
and milk bottles and bananas
and a tiny little room
in a Columbia building.
That's another thing I
tell my students, you know,
when Sturtevant was a sophomore,
he discovered gene mapping, you know,
you might consider doing
something like that, too.
But,
okay, so there are these
apparently irrelevant questions,
and of course, they lead
back 70 or 80 years later,
to exactly what the other
school wanted to do.
So there are lessons that we can draw
from the history of science.
If you actually think of this
as a process in which, you know,
you do the best you can.
And part of doing the best you can
is to take on some ventures
whose relevance isn't immediate.
Now, of course, you can
always choose wrongly.
You can always back the wrong people
who look terribly bright
and excited about some idea,
and it may lead nowhere.
But it seems to me that
if you were thinking
about directions in
which science could go,
how could you do better than this?
How could you do better
than attend to human needs,
in the light of all the evidence,
which actually includes the very phenomena
that you're pointing to?
I mean,
I think informed democracy
here is the best we've got.
But it's not perfect.
- There's a question I really
want to ask you, but Hannah.
- [Hannah] Oh, thank you,
thanks very much for that,
it was really interesting.
I wanted to go back to the distinction
that you made at the beginning between,
I think it was teleological
progress towards a goal,
and pragmatic progress where
you're working from something.
- I think I know what this
question is going to be,
but ask it anyway.
- [Hannah] I was gonna say,
why don't you go ahead and answer it?
- No no no, why don't
you ask it, and then--
- [Hannah] Well I first had
a kind of question about the,
how the distinction works,
but also how important it is
to the larger things that you
want to do in this project.
And the kind of question
that's internal to it
is that when I think about progress
from a problematic situation,
I think about the notion of a problem.
And on the face of it
a problem is something
that kind of impedes
you from doing something
that you want to do, or aim to do.
So even though I do get and like the idea
about a contrast between moving from
and moving to a clearly defined goal,
it does seem to me that
there's something teleological
built into the idea, even of the pragmatic
progress.
Was that the question you were expecting?
- Yes.
Yes, and it's a very important question.
And so I'm glad to have the
opportunity to answer it.
You're right, there's gotta be something
which we might think of as a local goal,
an end in view.
Because what I want is
relief from the problem,
so in that sense, I've got,
but I was a little bit more
careful than I sometimes
am today because I did say
a fixed long term goal.
So let me give you an example
that is supposed to warm you
up for seeing the difference
between what we might
think of as local teleology
or local,
you know, local goal directedness,
and what I was calling teleology,
in the having a fixed
long term goal sense.
Okay, so I,
a pretty poor gardener these days.
And I look at my flower
bed, and it's dreary,
and it's full of weeds,
and I wanna do something about it.
And I have a number of desiderata.
And these desiderata may
not be jointly satisfiable,
okay, that's an important
part of the story.
I want lots of color,
I want blooms at different
times of the summer.
You know, I want a harmony of colors,
I want easy care.
I want it to be drought resistant,
and blah blah blah blah blah.
So what do I do?
I start out in a particular direction,
I buy some seeds,
I use these ideas in
sort of starting up buying some plants
and putting seeds in and watering,
and, you know, some years later,
after numerous experiments and trials
and applications of these desiderata,
and others that have
cropped up in the meantime,
I get something and I
say, this is pretty good,
this is the sort of thing I wanted.
Going back to Alver's point,
it could have gone in
any number of different directions, right?
I wanna say that in a certain sense,
that wasn't teleological, I didn't have,
as it were at the beginning, a fixed goal.
I had a problem in the sense
of something that was unsatisfactory,
it's unsatisfactoriness
was associated with various desiderata,
but you know, I revised
some of the desiderata along the way.
And it's all been a sort of contingent,
path directed process.
The deeper question you're asking is,
how do you identify
problems, what's a problem,
and that is a very deep question,
but I want to say much
more about that tomorrow.
That is, I mean, that's a really
deep and serious question.
And anyone who wants
to talk about progress,
as I want to talk about it,
has to have an answer to that question.
- I'd like to ask you about the relation
between the conception of
progress that you're roughing out,
and the conception of progress
that the scientists, or the artists,
the practitioners themselves,
and what they're doing.
I mean, if I'm an artist,
and my overriding objective
is to make something
truly avant garde, I don't
care about the public good.
I mean, the public good
can go and get stuffed,
I want to do something
that moves things on.
If you think about psychiatry,
psychiatrists really aren't really,
what's the word I want, bothered
about whether there has really
been progress in psychiatry.
Now, from the point of
view of the public good,
there's clearly been a lot
of progress in psychiatry.
I mean, patients are no longer
bundled into unfunded asylums,
and standards of clinical
care are a lot better.
But when psychiatrists torture about
whether there's been any progress,
what they mean is that for,
especially for complex
disorders like schizophrenia,
or major depression,
they don't understand what's going on
any better than they did a century ago.
That's the fear,
that when you're looking for
the nuts and bolts of it,
and it's not really an
issue about the public good,
you would not assuage that worry,
maybe we're not making any
progress in psychiatry,
by saying, but look the
standards of clinical care
are improved out of all recognition.
That's not what they mean.
Or if, sorry.
- Again, it's like the question
that was asked down here,
it's two questions, and
they're both good ones,
and they're both ones
that I need to face up to.
Let me deal with the psychiatrist first.
So the psychiatrists
may well be in the grip
of what I call the official view, right?
So they may be thinking, what we gotta do
is tell the truth about the human psyche,
and the way it gets
disordered in various ways.
And that may blind them to
one of the modes of progress,
I mean, part of my view allows,
and you can see this in the way that
I talked about the
contributions of science
not being simply sets of propositions,
but also techniques
and so on and so forth,
is that you might make
progress in one mode.
And even though you were making
no progress whatsoever in another mode,
and what I want to say
about the psychiatrist,
is that they're, because they perhaps
have inherited this official view
in its application to psychiatry,
they've overlooked an important mode
of psychiatric progress,
which is in forms of practical care.
Okay, so that's the way
I would deal with that.
So what about the artists?
So the artists are also, I mean,
the artist you describe is very much
in an internal tradition
with which that artist is interacting.
It's not just, you know,
I wanna do something avant garde,
but rather, I've got
ideas about where to take,
you know, abstract expressionism next,
or I've got an idea about
where to go next with 12 tone music,
or what minimalism should do next.
So that's very much again, you know,
the idea of there being
sort of an internal
sort of standard that's
cut off from the public.
But there are other artists whom I think
are moved by the fact that
the kind of art that is being produced
doesn't speak to certain
classes of people.
So some artists, I think,
are moved to say, look,
what we need is a new form of music,
because everybody's, you know,
I mean, the young are not turned on by,
you know, sort of the high music
that has gotten such a lot
of status in the culture.
What we need is crossover stuff,
Radiohead, and Radiohead
needs to come to terms
with Ligaty, and then
we'll put the two together
and we're gonna make something fantastic.
And that's much more outwardly directed,
it seems to me, so it depends,
and you can think of this in
terms of the novel, right?
I mean, you know,
the marginalized audiences to
whom my novel will now speak.
And that, I think that's a genuine,
there you see the social stuff coming,
and so I think it's a mixture.
But it's a really good
thing to think about.
- I guess I have a background
Quinian kind of worry about...
If you said my conception of progress is
picked up from what's
internal to each discipline,
and what the practitioners are
thinking in each discipline,
that would be one take.
But as you presented it,
your conception of progress
seems to come from outside
any particular discipline
to be something that's
being worked out a priori.
- No, not a priori,
but actually in terms
of a wider reflection,
which I pointed to at both
the beginning and the end.
I mean, the conception of progress comes,
is really wrestling with skepticism
about the very idea.
The very idea of progress,
what is it to talk about?
And that skepticism is
partly based on the idea of,
yeah, you can talk about progress internal
to one of these enterprises or domains.
But when you enlarge the frame
and you look at the human consequences,
I mean, if you think
about all of the people
who are saying, who are
deriding the idea of progress,
they're all moved by this thought
that as you expand your vision, right,
so take a very simple example.
We both grew up on an island
that made fantastic economic progress
in the 19th century, right?
Expand the frame,
look at the places that
were feeding into that.
And you wanna say, no,
it's compromised by all of that,
it's compromised by the
exploitation of India
and so on and so forth.
And it's precisely that move,
the move of expanding the frame.
And so that's what pushes me,
and it pushes me in the genetics case,
I mean I was challenged by
the very first question.
That challenges me to
look at the ways in which
the consequences pan out
for the broader society.
Because it seems to me,
that's where you have to
respond to skepticism.
So it's not a priori,
but it's based not only on looking
at the internal constraints
of the discipline,
but also at a broader set of facts
about how that discipline is situated,
that then, if not attended to,
foster this kind of worry and
skepticism about progress.
Does that make sense?
- [John] That makes perfect sense.
- Okay, good.
- Last call.
- [Audience Member] I think
I just wanna follow up
this conversation you were
just having with John,
'cause it does seem like
you're tying progress,
potentially too much to
its actual effects on,
you know, the flourishing of
people in the broader society.
I mean, it seems like there's
a perfectly intelligible narrative
where there's all kinds
of progress going on
in the science and the arts.
If you start from the
internal perspective,
the problems get more and more difficult
and challenging and
potentially inaccessible.
And so the benefits of engaging with them
become harder for the society
to realize in some ways,
but you might say, there's
a lot of progress going on.
Unfortunately, as we've disinvested
in education simultaneously
with the problems becoming,
you know, more and more challenging
to understand on their own terms,
the benefits of this
progress are accessible
to an ever smaller set of people.
I want to say about that situation,
it might still be the case that if people
could acquire an
appreciation for the things
that are going on in
the different domains,
it would enrich their
lives in all kinds of ways
counter factually, but it isn't, in fact,
because they don't have the educational
opportunities and so on,
it seems like in that situation,
we do have progress, but
it's not bringing about
the kinds of Deweyan benefits
that you're pointing to.
So what do you say about that?
- I say that
a fourth part of the
logic of progress concepts
is that you're always looking at a frame.
And you can take the internal frame,
and we can say, I mean, we
do say a lot of the time,
this scientific domain
is making rapid progress,
and we don't even think about
whether the questions
that are being answered
have social merit or anything like that.
So that seems to me perfectly reasonable.
But when,
I think the skeptics and the cynics say,
enlarge the frame, see if
your judgment is stable
when you enlarge the frame.
And what they want from progress
is something that when you
move to the widest frame,
which is probably the impact on humans,
and maybe more than humans,
across, you know, not only the present,
but also the future,
turns out to be positive.
So it's as if you could
imagine a sequence of frames that get
wider and wider and wider.
The thought is that real progress is,
look at the narrowest frame, it's there,
you enlarge the frame, it's there,
it continues, it's stable
as you enlarge the frame.
So that's the thought.
Now, the example that you
gave was really interesting,
because of course, you
can get this situation,
and it almost came up in the question,
there was another scenario
that was very close
to the two that were offered at the back.
Where you think about a
scientific development,
like the discovery of quantum mechanics,
which from the internal point
of view is really important.
And then in the 30s,
starts to trouble various people
because it enables the production
of these extraordinary weapons, okay?
Now, what happens if you get
an awful social consequence because
a scientific, piece of
scientific understanding,
answer to what seemed to
be a very good question,
gets translated.
So this is exactly what I'm thinking of
as institutional friction,
you can have an
institution of policymaking
that surrounds the science
and translates it into practice,
that does horrible things,
even though the institution
itself is not guilty.
So that can happen,
and that I think happens
in the case you imagine,
where, as it were,
the sciences are making
these wonderful benefits,
but the educational system is science,
science is so dismal and deteriorating,
that the effect on the broader
public isn't appreciated.
So, absolutely, I mean,
so there's a lot to be
said here about frames
and the interactions among
institutions within society.
Yeah.
And I hope to say all of it at some point.
And better than I just did.
- That was wonderful.
Lucid, deep, unexpected,
thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(gentle electronic music)